[Music]
the only men of your caught are those
who don't love their wives enough mister
Lampros is dead
BAM Donald his driver mister the Lampros
gave me certain instructions he wants
the flat cleared out so I'm gonna have
to ask you to leave
senior the truth is I met a half-naked
girl me dead bosses flat but the
psychopathic ex-husband is also a drug
dealer and he's about to marry a 15 year
old 16 what are you gonna do now you're
gonna run are you for the blessing of
your father and mother thousand people
will witness my marriage to midium don't
we find a particularly interesting video
on Father's five Tammy and I made a deal
receptionist a lawyer call it quits I'm
gonna need your help to clear all signs
of this girl
you know what will happen where's amber
I don't know tell me where amber is
Shirley
why did you keep me a secret but the
courage to stand up and tell the truth
could never pay me back for what I've
done
they don't care about the truth bad
things happen to bad people
Renu this wedding is not gonna happen
is she
[Music]
your lies have brought us into this
after your funeral I will still marry
Matt him I was given the job to do as
far as I was concerned once it was done
that was their job Oh
why does identically the devil because I
like playing with fire
[Music]
you